jacques trémolat c'est une histoire de
chair justement vous allez nous raconte
eric chen prairie casque sexologie sean
connery sur des marmottes jean ressemble
exactement à nos marmotte sa vie comme
elle sauf que ça ne dort pas en hiver ça
dort pas en hiver sa vie dans des
terriers compliqué et comme les
marmottes ça mange des petites herbes
seulement comme ça aboie et que sa
habitat grande près riom et j'appelle
des chaînes prairies à ceci près que ce
sont des citadins les chaînes prairie
vivra en ville ils se font des villes de
leur terrier on a compté qu'une de ces
cités et comptait 40 millions
d'habitants alors comprenez new york
chicago doit aller se rhabiller 40
millions d'habitants la ville la plus
importante des états unis les chaînes
prairies et ces villes sont divisés en
quartier et chaque quartier à son chef
qui est en général le grand père de tous
les gens qui habitent le quartier et au
milieu du quartier il ya toujours un
petit monticule en terre c'est toute la
terre qu'ils ont tiré les terriers et
sur lequel il ya toujours un guetteur
qui surveille parce qu'ils ont des
ennemis des chaînes prairies les coyotes
les loups les hommes les chiens et puis
les rapaces qui risque d'aller prendre
alors ils guettaient richesse à tous et
qui regarde de tous les côtés tout le
temps puis dès qu'il voit un adversaire
un danger quelconque il aboie et tout le
monde rentre dans ces trous
naturellement quand on est jeune
prairies on préfère habiter le centre où
il ya moins de danger que la banlieue
mais ces grandes villes puisque
évidemment le coyote qui traînent dans
la prairie il a plus facilement le moyen
d'attaquer le chat noir lieu que celui
qui habite au milieu de la grande ville
peut pas y aller il faut d'ajouter enfin
que les chaînes prairies comme nos
marmotte s'amuse tout le temps y joue
tout le temps dès qu'ils ont mangé où
ils jouent ils jouent à se poursuivre
les joues à faire semblant de se battre
il joue à faire des trophées ils
s'amusent ils sont terriblement
affectueux quand deux chaînes près
risquant constituante dans les bras l'un
l'autre qui s'embrassent et ils
s'embrassent et puis on va remplacer
celui qui est le tour de gué la bad sur
au tour de guet pas près de 7 sur les
joues absolument charmant et qu'ils
s'adorent mais il arrive que dans un
quartier donné il est un chien de
prairie ambitieux j'ai un effort et qui
a bien envie de passer chef de quartier
chez les loups par exemple très simple
il retrouvé le chef de plomb ils ont
créé une trouble il passerait chef de
clan mais les chiens de prairies sont
beaucoup plus civilisée et pour passer
chef de quartier c'est lui il faudrait
qu'ils attaquent son grand-père qu'il
faut qu'une troupe à son grand père et
ça ne se fait pas moi je trouve ça très
bien et il peut pas parler disons que
les olobe disent qu'il ya une inhibition
sociale je m'excuse est un mot savant
qui l'empêchent d'aller planquer une
ruche de son grand père alors il ya le
quartier d'à côté ce serait très simple
il suffirait d'entrer dans le quartier
d'à côté d'aller trouver le chef de lui
flanquer une trompinette d'unir chef à
sa place mais ça ne marcherait pas car
l'expérience prouve que coûte un chien
de prairie du quartier la côte est a
rossé le chef de ce quartier là et on
voulait prendre sa place les gens du
quartier plutôt que d'obéir à quelqu'un
qui ne connaissent pas qui n'ont jamais
vu déménager et les malheureux aller
s'installer en banlieue dans les
endroits extrêmement dangereux et le l'a
séduit tout seul comme un idiot au
milieu du quartier alors c'est pas comme
ça qu'ils vont faire alors quand un
chien de prairie ambitieux veut passer
chef de quartier du quartier voisin
qu'est ce qui fait une campagne
électorale
ah bon oui comme on le voit dans
certains pays et dans certains cas de
canton à canton alors il commence
d'abord mais c'est très subtil
l'engagement qu'il l'a fait il commence
par rentrer dans le quartier à côté ce
qui est défendu chez les chiens de
prairie on n'en trouve pas chez le
voisin on le chasse au pardon joindre il
s'en va une heure après il revient on le
chasse aux excusez moi il revient encore
à force de chasser et qui reviennent et
il fait de mal à personne on finit par
prendre l'habitude on l'a toujours vu il
fait pas de mal aux gens au bout de ces
tuiles ou et puis surtout il ya pris
l'odeur du quartier à force de traîner
dans le quartier de rochas tout le temps
il m'avait pris l'eau d'heure alors on
prend l'habitude alors à ce moment là
vraiment c'est sa campagne électorale
qui commence il fait le gentil quand il
a trouvé une herbe de retraite à one il
va chercher un petit chien très rude à
côté du quartier là et lui dise à élan
lollia manger il va jouer avec les
autres qui jouent à creuser les terriers
petit à petit on autorise à faire son
terrier dans le quartier il est reçu il
va remplacer le guetteur sur la tour de
guet il est maintenant chez lui dans le
quartier on le considère comme un chien
de prairie de ce quartier là et à ce
moment là et à ce moment là seulement
notre chaîne prairie ambitieux peut
aller trouver le chef de quartier il lui
fit une 30 et ils pas chefs de quartiers
et les autres ils obéissent et c'est
comme ça qu'on fait une campagne
électorale dans la grande prairie
américaine josaine à tandis que ce sont
des histoires pour enfants moi je trouve
ce sont des histoires aussi pour lundi
latine ont tout le monde écoute et on
est on est passionné chaque fois parole
jacques trémolet